I love action movies especially 90s
action James Cameron John Woo and I
wanna bring that to life on YouTube now
one of the challenges we face on YouTube
is time most movies have a lot of time
for their action scenes for example the
bathroom fight in Mission Possible they
had two weeks to film that we only have
two days to film our entire video I'm
going to show you how to direct errs get
over that challenge of a time limit as
well as how to make anything into a cool
action scene by the way check out this
cool t-shirt quarter did y'all that
story so do video boards like this for a
lot of action sequences especially one
like I'm not having a ton of time to
prep on locations it's a prep
application we shoot with our phone
don't worry about looking good it's not
even really about framing so much as it
is did I get this shot in dude they get
this shot I need it making sure we have
the right beats and the action flows
from shots shots and once you have a
plan you can deviate from it can't
deviate from the plan
you don't have a plan son suit once sit
in the arm for best laid plans never
survive eating the enemy the enemies
today is just getting the video done
also for you also easy to tell you that
has awesome D&D podcast if you're fans
of Dungeons & Dragons you should go
check out its podcast dungeons and
daddys there's a link in the description
below and I'm gonna plug it multiple
times for this video so you better go
check it out you got enough dolls Jake
and that kids man so you'll end up like
me
with a whole stash of dolls today we're
she being attacked too cool reloads it's
the first time that we've gotten to use
the perfect camera rig so if you guys
didn't see the perfect camera video
there's actually a link down in the
description you could put a lot of time
into creating a system that would allow
us to switch camera configurations super
quickly this allows us to switch to a
shoulder rig for coverage on the fly a
slider for those nice dolly shots and
then a gimbal if you want that smooth
handheld look
definitely isn't my third time ever
doing this I think I got pretty well
balanced for the 24 little eye isn't
gonna be relevant
yeah Liza is gonna be the the perfect
camera the perfect camera dude she's
actually on screen challenge you never
know what you're gonna get when you put
a two-and-a-half-year-old in front of
the camera but generally she's pretty
good you just got to pick your battles I
can't get her acting yet if I do then by
the time we actually have to do the take
she's gonna be bored I just let her run
as long as we get this shot in the next
hour before she gets tired for a nap we
call them the same with me like in about
an hour hour and a half I'm gonna conk
out thinking that
[Music]
this works
oops wrong way very easy it was just a
snap tactical camera reloads yes right
here and I said wait right there
[Music]
she'll come back oh sweet right but you
I'll show you this in third grade all
right so we're about to go into the
first true reload sequence so this is
where they are reloading a coffee
machine so I have the video board it
made it Clint we're gonna try to apply
it to here kind of you know spaces a
little different source whit like
clipping some things and mirroring some
things hopefully it doesn't get too
complicated but having that video board
should be useful shoulder mount it's so
much faster than taking off your plate
unscrewing it putting on the new plate
and just snap it right on
there's a super quick yeah this shot
we're about to get already make sure
top-down we're not gonna do that
paperwork walks up this goes the best
we're at this part now where he turns
away and smacks it that's pretty good
[Music]
kitchen scene went wonderful Lee having
the video board and made it really
actually really easy to go through the
whole thing I wasn't trying to like make
up the sequence in the middle of filming
the sequence which is not a good way to
do things but in operating the camera
like the past couple hours and that's
miss chilling really hard right now
because it's not that heavy but once you
hold it in your shoulder for a couple of
hours it gets kind of heavy what you
have right here is the greatest
close-quarters combat tactical
innovation in the history of firearms I
present you the gun stock in a home
defense scenario there's a perp let's
say I got you here what are you gonna do
see with the gun stock you buy yourself
the ability to get the upper hand in any
close quarters combat scenario observe
who was gonna do oh no now what he still
has the slot and I still have the gun
that disarming attempt instantly negated
by the fact that I had the gun side
it's not for that you would disarm me
and I'd be dead but thanks to the gun
sock
I live to fight another day unstoppable
no one can ever disarm you if you have
the guns on once hey the guys got and
checked out Freddie's podcast yet
dungeons and daddys it's not a BDSM
podcast if you search for dungeon guys
just saw its own on Google you'll get
search results that you may not be
looking for so now we're moving on to
the living room scene where the
battery's already loaded into the remote
control and believe it or not I also
video board at this scene the video
board for the scene is a little more
rough though so we'll see how it goes
I'm hoping it goes smoothly however
after like potentially mirror the whole
thing the hardest part is I need to find
one spot in the room where I can have
all the mirrors show Freddy and that
show me with the camera four mirrors is
how many mirrors we need I need a pan
between each one
[Music]
but hey what's up I'm working so hard
right now
[Music]
we're gonna take a pillow when I throw
at this and adjust it okay okay run my
greatest role you're a mirror are you
ready Freddie oh yeah power like grace
look at that precision though who's
throwing that okay so now all right with
the help of the video board I always am
one step ahead okay ready
Colin bicep mount so you just you know
you put on your guns and you use this
pop zooms all day too shaky because my
biceps are just so huge action action
[Music]
and length and length and fling finished
first day of tech - cool reloads I felt
great about the shoot this mood look
great the camera rig worked great
hey you might be wondering why is Jake
standing in the middle of the frame now
when I was just watching that video well
it's because I wanted to tell you guys
about this amazing merchandise that we
had created in celebration of the
original tactical reloads video and now
the second one Oh what is that a
bandanna look at that that's a t-shirt
you might even have a t-shirt on right
now if you do you could be thinking hey
I could have that t-shirt on that's
right it's available right now hey let
me ask you guys a question
when's the last time you guys looked at
a windbreaker and thought that's cool
right now exactly because this
windbreaker is tacticool anybody looks
great in it you got an ugly grandma go
ahead and give her a windbreaker she's
gonna look great I brought this pistol
with me because the more merchandise
that you guys buy the more we can stick
it to the brands they don't like guns
and videos but since this is our
merchandise isn't that not brand safe
demonetised
everybody likes these black long-sleeved
t-shirts well guess what we put some
sweet graphics on the sleeves and also
we had this design Sam and I worked with
an awesome artist
we put a lot of thought into it it's all
limited-edition stuff you're never gonna
see it again in the store so if you like
the videos if you like this much please
go on check it out at court or do two
about store all the money goes to making
these videos so we'll see you out there
all right day two of tacticool reloads
haven't had a lot of time to prep
because they've been traveling so much
it's the climactic action scene of the
whole piece we don't have video boards
for the reload I'm imagining it's gonna
be way less smooth than
when we had the video board that means
we have to figure it out now choreograph
here thankfully Freddy's a tactical
genius and with our powers combined we
are captain reload and we got I mean we
got a script so that helps the words
have been decided that we say speaking
of scripts let me go find it I'll be
right back
[Music]
so first thing is on Freddy hands come
to the ears close his eyes are you
playing for I get this reality bang old
stuff goes off just me Freddy like step
into frame turns like walking this way
and you see like one clown like widen up
a single bullet tosses it in the air a
little more the lens come on
almost come on you can do it that's
close almost
[Music]
that was it and then spin who's around
and basically right when you land here
the ball it falls it goes fast that's
great
the challenge of shooting a piece like
this is there are a ton of setups you
can do about 40 setups today see what
this way every setup takes 15 minutes
from beginning to end
the moment you start at the moment you
end so that's 4 setups an hour 10 hour a
day 40 setups if you believe you can do
a scene with more than 60 setups in a
day you are kidding yourself
and are not in touch with reality so
it's lunchtime I'm going to just offload
all the red files to be safe what I'm
gonna do while we eat lunch is just plug
our red mini mag dumper right into this
let's see DJI copilot it's gonna
automatically dump all the files on
which is really nice
these things are great it's huge you
should be go buy good red if you just
walked out in the middle of the street
here in that outfit good wait how long
before a cop ices you
I actually I just killed someone at a
Juggalo gathering and now I am trying to
escape
all right let's shoot this really fast
got it I gotta take before my arms are
done we're on a quarter battery right
keeps using this give me until it runs
on the Battie both slinger makes at you
laugh at him out of your way you're both
full of eggs we toss them to each other
catch them we could just toss the eggs
and catch the eggs and our guns we just
like backhand each other and they go
you're almost done is he heavy singer
then run to the martini but what a B
singer second last shot a B singer
second martini be in the last at some
film terminology for all of you people
I hope you've entertained your eyeholes
but if you're looking for some ear hole
entertainment we have a new podcast Oh
dungeon at ease which is a Dungeons &
Dragons podcast that we play and it's a
lot of fun it's about four dads and
they're in the fantasy world of Dungeons
& Dragons like actual dads so I do it
with Madden will co-creators vGHS
Anthony our friends comic-book writer
and from Beth we sound design out the
pile so it's like there's definitely
like music and a link in the description
below
it's just google it you you find it just
find it you idiot what do you go use the
internet anyway dungeons and daddies go
check it out what you can do a standing
kick but you can't just kick off know
what when you
you messed the order up get on it I'll
push you no one no one's actually ever
done the full detail in that only house
tried to land the full potato